andy is a furniture refinisher who runs
the youtube channel modern makeovers
this dresser was made in the 1920s
over years of use the veneer is starting
to peel off there are marker drawings on
it and the stain is starting to age andy
shows us how he restores this dresser by
removing the old veneer and replacing it
with new veneer strips removing the old
stain and applying a new coat repairing
the handles and applying a top coat to
seal in all his work
the veneer on this dresser is severely
damaged and unsalvageable
andy is using a heat gun and a putty
knife to strip it off
the heat softens the glue between the
veneer and the dresser so that the wood
underneath won't get damaged as he
strips it
he sands the whole piece down to bare
wood
this makes it easier for the stain to
absorb when he applies it later on in
the process
now he's applying a paint stripper to
the sides of the dresser to remove the
old stain
it sits for 15 minutes then he scrubs
the area with steel wool
andy is replacing the old veneer with
veneer edge bandings
he arranges the strips carefully
considering the width grain pattern and
color of each
once he's happy with how they look he
numbers them to make sure he can put
them back in the same order
and is covering the surrounding areas
with painters tape in order to protect
them
he applies a generous amount of contact
cement to the strips with a roller as
well as the section of the dresser he'll
be applying the strips to in order to
get a strong adhesion
andy waits 15 minutes and then does a
touch test if the contact cement isn't
tacky to the touch the strips are ready
to go on
[Music]
he is applying one strip at a time to
make sure the application is perfect
then using a wooden stick with a rounded
edge he presses down hard across the
entire surface to make sure it is fully
adhered
he repeats this process one strip at a
time until the entire top of the dresser
is covered
[Music]
and is breaking off the excess length of
the strips and sanding the edges smooth
to give the front edge of the veneer a
cleaner finish he adds a thin strip of
wood to blanket the edges of the veneer
strips
andy is doing this by cutting a piece of
scrap wood with a table saw and applying
it to the dresser with wood glue
[Music]
he is restaining the body of the piece
with an oil stain
andy slathers the stain on with a brush
and then wipes it away with a towel
he is removing the handles from the
drawers so he can work on them
separately
andy sands the existing finish on the
drawers in order to apply a new finish
[Music]
he is applying paint stripper to the
handles using a brush
after 15 minutes you can scrub away the
stain and finish on the handles using a
scratch brush
andy is staining the handles using a
water-based stain in black
he applies the stain using a pair of
socks
cotton is lint free and highly absorbent
making it a perfect tool for staining
he uses a water-based topcoat to seal
the drawers and the body of the dresser
after years of use this peeling dresser
is now a fully repaired piece that is
ready to be used again
you